Gojo finally released as he faces two of
the strongest fighters ever kenjaku and
sukuna it doesn't get more hype than
this so make sure to stay tuned for this
insane chapter smash that like button
like Gojo smash through that seal if you
want to see more Jujutsu Kaizen videos
on the channel make this the video you
joined the Jujutsu fan by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications so you don't
miss future jjk videos and updates so
straight into the chapter and we
straight up have the narrator hyping us
up letting us know that it is time to
let Gojo loose with of course two
exclamation marks but before that we get
some lead up to that epic Moment by the
way this chapter is called gain and loss
but I think we all know Gojo showing up
is more gain than loss but who knows
with tsukuna in megumi's body the losses
might be heavy too so it starts with
Yuji and friends talking about the seal
in front of them with Gojo in it Angel
asks if they are planning on releasing
Gojo here and Yuji is like yeah can't we
I like the joke brought up that it's a
bit of a dull place for a homecoming and
they could try adding interlock to rings
Soul fighting but Angel soon explains
that that's not what she meant we then
learned a bit about how time flows in
the sealed prison realm so how it might
have flowed for Gojo and its interesting
stuff we're told it is said time does
not flow within the prison realm so
whatever is trapped inside will not die
due to starvation or old age so that's
the good news the prisoner will live
indefinitely unless they end their own
life an interesting detail but we know
Gojo wouldn't do that but of course it's
not that simple it never is we're told
it can't just be used as a time machine
because there is no concept of physical
time it is impossible for them to know
how Gojo has perceived the last 19 days
since Halloween it could have felt like
a blink of an eye but at the same time
it's possible it could have felt like
100 years or even more a very
interesting detail so at least in terms
of the 100 years alternative there is
the fear that Gojo's mental state could
be messed up right now since he's the
strongest Sorcerer of the current
generation if he's in mental disarray on
doing the seal in a narrow space like
the room they are in could be a very
dangerous Yuji admits that when you put
it that way it sounds really dangerous
and bonus points to the mangaka for how
this panel is Illustrated I love it Gojo
Godzilla for the win if anything
deserves a like a smash that like button
it's Gojo Godzilla so they find a wide
open space and as we've known for a
while Angel is gonna be the one to undo
the seal it's fitting that an angel will
be the one to bring back Humanity's only
remaining hope so it happens and at
first there's a joke because it
disappears and people start to think
that maybe when the back of the prison
realm is exposed to Angel's curse
technique Gojo's wife from existence
it's so Bleak and hilarious that I love
it I love the comedy in this series I
must say angel comes in defending
herself saying hey maybe Gojo is evil so
he disappeared when exposed to angel
light so it's not Angel's fault right
right and to be fair Gojo's personality
has some evil to it as some people point
out but of course as the narrator told
us things go according to plan and Gojo
is released this chapter and it's crazy
the characters realize this is happening
when they feel an earthquake the prison
realm it's revealed was placed at the
subduction zone 8 000 meters below the
surface in the Japan trench that in and
of itself is crazy hype cursed Spirits
were even placed to act as censors
beneath the multiple layers of seals
over top and there is no break we go
from this to the same page being kenjaku
face to face with Gojo gotta respect the
lack of filler here from release to
facing the main bad guys immediately
kinjaku says tangent told him all about
the back after being absorbed and
supposedly even if the seal Were Somehow
broken Gojo would perish too but that's
of course not the case and we see Gojo
there in what we can only imagine would
be a accompanied by the most epic music
in the anime itself so can't wait for
this part to be animated kenjaku asks
how in the world he did it and we see
Gojo's face which in and of itself is so
hype after he has been sealed away for
so long I didn't even realize how much I
missed Gojo until I saw his face right
here I love kinjaku's sense of humor too
though he says it's been a long time
since you were truly able to relax so he
asks how was it as if he did Gojo a
favor by sealing him and giving him some
time to relax I feel like I laughed more
than the average person during this
chapter but man there were a lot of
funny parts Gojo then responds in Epic
fashion he says hey you should choose
your words more carefully after all they
will be your last
so cool but goju is interrupted by
sukuna who as we know isn't megumi's
body right now Gojo immediately notices
saying you've changed quite a bit since
the last time I saw you megumi this of
course adds another factor to the fight
not only is Gojo facing two of the
strongest Bad Dudes ever he has to think
about how he's fighting megumi's body
someone very important to him and who
has been very important to him for a
very long time one of the things I
really like about the Stratos how it
brings back past statements that we
might have already forgotten about by
now but are super relevant right now
like sukuna for example brings up when
he said after I take this Brat's body
for myself you'll meaning Gojo will be
the first person I kill tsukuna
reasserts that he'll kill Gojo here the
hype is just off the charts man people
always talk Gojo vs sukuna as the most
hype matchup and it's happening right
now before our eyes Gojo is still having
fun talking smack and you gotta love it
he says to sukuna you a loser that had
to run away from Yuji coming with your
tail between your legs is pretty
pathetic after Gojo deals with the
father in record time kenjaku comes in
telling sukuna to wait he says he has to
make good on his promise to him first
Gojo as lighthearted and hilarious as
ever frames this as the great tsukuna
nicely obeying instructions from his
mommy while to himself Gojo thinks there
are some things he would like to take
care of before the fight as well he'd
like to give suguru's body a proper
burial and he thinks who would have
thought tsukuna got so close to the
person inhabiting him he can't help but
think what a pain it is and it makes
sense because these are two very
powerful dudes tag teaming sukuna
perhaps surprisingly shows patience and
says that's fine with him postponing the
fight seems to work for everyone or at
least that's the way it seems at the
moment Gojo hilariously asks man what
day is it even and he's told it's
November 19th he asks how about they do
it 24th of December if you didn't know
Christmas in Japan is the most romantic
day of the year don't ask me why I don't
know but yeah Christmas is a time for
romance dates and even marriage
proposals in Japan so with this in mind
it's not surprising kenjaku says
how romantic having a date with you
meaning Gojo on Christmas Eve gives me
the creeps while Gojo says having two
death anniversaries will make things
complicated no can jock who smiles and
asks you think you can win while Gojo
drops up oozing that trademark Gojo
confidence that we all love so much and
then again as I mentioned we get an
earlier conversation brought up here
because it is super relevant now and
it's one of the most hype statements
that was brought up ever in the series
it's when Sensei Gojo was asked who's
stronger full strength tsukuna or goji
Joe and Gojo remember said it would be a
tad difficult but he would win and now
we get a full page of his epic face
reaffirming that he will win as he says
the narrator says a declaration of
Victory right after his comeback with of
course two exclamation marks again and
we expect nothing less of Gojo the man
the myth the legend after that Hiatus we
all know he'll deliver an epic fashion
however the story won't make it too easy
for sure so we're definitely in for some
suspense and epic battles let me know
who do you think will win Gojo or sukuna
combined with kenjaku if any tag team
stands a chance against Gojo it has to
be this one and if you're interested in
the other strongest Sorcerers in jjk
like Gojo and including Gojo then you
won't want to miss our all special grade
Sorcerers and their powers explained
video link on screen to that right now
and in the description see you there